Se nos ha dicho que nos arriesguemos y digamos algo sorprendente.
Así que trataré de hacerlo. Pero
Quiero comenzar con dos cosas que todos ya sabemos.
Y la primera, en realidad, es algo que
se ha sabido a lo largo de casi toda la historia conocida.
y es que el planeta Tierra, o el Sistema Solar,
o nuestro medio ambiente, o lo que sea
está únicamente adaptado para sostener nuestra evolución -- o creación, como se acostumbraba a pensar --
nuestra existencia actual, y lo más importante, nuestra supervivencia futura.
Actualmente esta idea tiene un nombre dramático: Nave Espacial Tierra
Y la idea es que fuera de la nave,
el Universo es implacablemente hostil,
y que dentro está todo lo que tenemos, todo aquello de lo que dependemos.
Y sólo tenemos esta única oportunidad: si destruimos nuestra nave,
no tenemos adonde más ir.
Ahora, lo segundo que todos saben es que
al contrario de lo que se creía en la mayor parte de la historia humana
los seres humanos no son el centro de la existencia.
Como Stephen Hawking dijo,
somo solamente una escoria química en la superficie de un planeta típico
que orbita a una estrella típica,
que está en las afueras de una galaxia típica, y así sigue.
Ahora la primera de las dos cosas que todos saben
es como decir que estamos en lugar muy atípico,
únicamente apropiado, etc., y
la segunda es decir que estamos en un lugar típico.
Y especialmente si vemos ambas como verdades profundas de nuestras vidas
y la base para nuestras decisiones vitales,
entonces parecen estar en conflicto entre ellas.
Pero eso no las libra a ambas de ser completamente falsas. (Risas)
Y lo son. Así que déjenme comenzar con la segunda:
Típico. Bueno -- ¿Es éste un lugar típico? Bueno, miremos alrededor,
y miremos en cualquier dirección,y vemos un muro, escoria química -- (Risas)
-- y eso no es típico del Universo en lo absoluto.
Todo lo que hay que hacer es ir unos cientos de millas en la misma dirección y mirar hacia atrás,
y no van a ver ningún muro ni ninguna escoria química --
sólo verán un planeta azul. Y si van más lejos,
verán el Sol, el Sistema Solar, y las estrellas, etc.
Pero eso aún no es típico del Universo, porque las estrellas se agrupan en galaxias.
Y la mayor parte de los lugares en el Universo, un lugar típico en él,
no está cerca de galaxia alguna.
Así que vamos más allá, hasta que salgamos de la galaxia y miremos atrás,
y, sí, ahí está la galaxia gigantesca con brazos espirales desplegada frente a nosotros.
En ese punto nos hemos alejado 100 000 años luz de aquí.
Pero, todavía no estamos cerca de un lugar típico del Universo.
Para ir a un lugar típico,
debemos ir 1 000 veces más lejos que eso, al espacio intergaláctico.
¿Y cómo se ve eso? Típico.
¿Cómo es un lugar típico del Universo?
Bien, con un gasto enorme, TED ha preparado una inmersión de alta resolución
de realidad virtual representando el espacio intergaláctico.
-- la vista desde el espacio intergaláctico.
¿Podemos apagar las luces, por favor, para poder verlo?
Bueno, no es tan perfecto -- verán, en el espacio intergaláctico
-- el espacio intergaláctico es completamente oscuro, muy oscuro.
Es tan oscuro que si uno mirara a la estrella más cercana,
y esa estrella explotara como una supernova,
y tu estuvieras mirando directamente a ella en el momento que su luz te llegara,
no serías capaz de ver ni un pequeño resplandor.
Así de grande y oscuro es el Universo.
Y eso a pesar que una supernova es tan brillante, un evento tan brillante,
que te mataría en un rango de varios años luz.
Pero, en el espacio intergaláctico, está tan lejos que ni la verías.
También hace mucho frío allí
-- menos de tres grados sobre el cero absoluto.
Y está muy vacío. El vacío ahí es un millón de veces menos denso
que el mayor vacío que nuestra mejor tecnología en la Tierra puede actualmente
crear. Así de diferente es un lugar típico de este lugar.
Y así de atípico es este lugar.
¿Podemos encender nuevamente las luces? Gracias.
Ahora, ¿Cómo es que sabemos acerca de un ambiente que está tan lejos,
es tan diferente, tan ajeno a todo lo que estamos acostumbrados?
Bueno, la Tierra -- nuestro ambiente, por nuestro intermedio -- está creando conocimiento.
¿Qué significa eso? Miremos aún más lejos de donde recién estuvimos --
Desde aquí, con un telescopio -- verán cosas que parecen estrellas.
Se las llama quasares. Quasar significaba originalmente objecto cuasi-estelar.
Que significa objetos que se ven como estrellas. (Risas) Pero, no son estrellas.
Y sabemos lo que son. Hace miles de millones de años, y miles de millones de años luz de aquí,
el material en el centro de una galaxia colapsó hacia un
agujero negro super masivo.
Y entonces, campos magnéticos intensos dirigieron una parte de la energía
de ese colapso gravitacional. Y parte de la materia,
volvió en la forma de chorros tremendos que iluminaron lóbulos con el brillo de
-- yo creo billones de soles.
Ahora, la física del cerebro humano no podría ser más diferente de la física de un chorro como ese.
No podríamos sobrevivir ni por un instante en él. El lenguaje no es capaz
de describir como sería estar en uno de esos chorros.
Sería como experimentar una explosión de una supernova,
pero en el origen mismo y por millones de años al mismo tiempo. (Risas)
Y sin embargo, ese chorro ocurrió precisamente en una forma tal que miles de millones de años después,
en el otro lado del Universo, un pedacito de escoria química pudo describir con exactitud,
y modelar, y predecir, y explicar, sobre todo -- ahí esta su referencia
-- lo que sucedía allí, en realidad.
Un sistema físico, el cerebro,
contiene un modelo exacto del otro -- el quasar.
No sólo una imagen superficial de él, aunque la contiene también,
sino que un modelo explicatorio, que incluye las mismas relaciones
matemáticas y la misma estructura causal.
Eso es conocimiento. Y si eso no fuera suficientemente raro,
la fidelidad con la que una estructura se parece a la otra
aumenta con el tiempo. Ese el crecimiento del conocimiento.
Así que, las leyes de la física tienen esa propiedad especial.
Que los objetos físicos, por muy diferentes que sean,
puede aún inluir la misma estructura matemática y causal
y pueden hacerlo cada vez más a lo largo del tiempo.
Somos, entonces, una escoria química diferente. esta escoria química tiene universalidad.
Su estructura contiene, con creciente precisión,
la estructura de todo. Este lugar, y no otros lugares en el Universo,
es un centro que contiene dentro de sí la esencia estructural y causal de
todo el resto de la realidad física. Y así, lejos de ser insignificante,
el hecho que las leyes de la física lo permitan, o incluso que obligan a que ésto suceda,
es una de las cosas más importantes acerca del mundo físico.
¿Cómo hace el Sistema Solar -- y nuestro medio ambiente, en la forma de nosotros --
para adquirir esta relación especial con el resto del Universo?
Bueno, una cosa es cierta acerca del comentario de Stephen Hawking -- es decir, es verdad,
pero tiene el énfasis equivocado. Lo que es cierto acerca de él es que
no necesita una física especial. No hay una dispensa especial,
no hay milagros. Lo hace simplemente con tres cosas que tenemos aquí en abundancia.
Una de ellas es la materia, por que el crecimiento del conocimiento es una forma de
procesamiento de información. Procesamiento de información es computación,
la computación requiere un computador --
no hay forma conocida de hacer un computador sin materia.
También necesitamos energía para hacer el computador, y lo más importante,
para hacer los medios sobre los cuales registramos el conocimiento que descubrimos.
y en tercer lugar, menos tangible, pero tan esencial para la creación ilimitada
de conocimiento, de explicaciones, es la evidencia.
Nuestro medio ambiente está inundado con evidencia.
Pasó que nos dedicamos a hacer pruebas --- por ejemplo la Ley de la Gravedad de Newton
-- hace unos 300 años.
Pero la evidencia que usamos para hacer eso caía sobre cada metro cuadrado
de la Tierra miles de millones de años antes, y continuará cayendo por miles de millones de años
después. Y lo mismo es cierto de todas las otras ciencias.
Hasta donde sabemos, la evidencia para descubrir las verdades más fundamentales
de todas las ciencias está aquí para que la tomemos en nuestro planeta.
Nuestro lugar está saturado de evidencia, y también de masa y de energía.
Allá afuera en el espacio intergaláctico, estos tres pre requisitos
para la creación ilimitada de conocimiento están en niveles mínimos de disponibilidad.
Como dije. está vacío, hace frío y está oscuro. ¿O no?
Ahora, en realidad, ese es sólo otro concepto provincial equivocado. (Risas).
Porque imaginen un cubo allá afuera en el espacio intergaláctico, del mismo tamaño que
nuestro hogar, el Sistema Solar. Ese cubo está muy vacío desde un punto de vista humano,
pero aún así contiene más de un millón de toneladas de masa.
Y un millón de toneladas es suficiente para hacer, digamos, una estación espacial auto contenida,
en la cual hay una colonia de científicos dedicados a crear un
flujo ilimitado de conocimiento, etc.
Ahora bien, está lejos del alcance de la tecnología actual incluso recoger el hidrógeno
del espacio intergaláctico y convertirlo en otros elementos y así sucesivamente.
Pero, el asunto es que, en un universo comprensible,
si algo no está prohibido por las leyes de la física,
entonces ¿Que podría impedírnos hacerlo, que no sea el saber cómo?
En otras palabras, es un asunto de conocimiento, no de recursos.
Y lo mismo -- bueno, si pudiéramos hacer eso automáticamente tendríamos una fuente de energía,
porque la transmutación sería un reactor de fusión -- ¿Y la evidencia?
De nuevo, está oscuro allá afuera para los sentidos humanos. Pero todo lo que tienen que hacer es
tomar un telescopio, basta uno con un diseño actual,
observen y verán las mismas galaxias que vemos desde aquí.
Y con un telescopio más potente, podrán ver estrellas, y planetas.
En esas galaxias, podrán hacer astrofísica, y aprender las leyes de la física.
Y localmente, podrán construir aceleradores de partículas allá,
y aprender física de partículas elementales, y química, y todo.
Es probable que la ciencia más dificil de realizar serían las salidas a campo biológicas, porque tardaría
varios centenares de millones de años llegar al planeta más cercano con capacidad para la vida y volver.
Debo decirles -- y lo siento, Richard --
pero nunca me gustaron mucho esas salidas a campo,
y creo que con una cada pocos cientos de millones de años es suficiente.
(Risas)
Así que, de hecho, el espacio intergaláctico no contiene todos los pre-requisitos para una ilimitada
creación de conocimiento. Cualquier cubo así, en cualquier parte del Universo,
podría convertirse en el mismo núcleo que nosotros somos,
si el conocimiento de cómo hacerlo estuviera presente allí.
Por lo tanto no estamos en un único lugar hospitalario.
Si el espacio intergaláctico es capaz de crear un flujo ilimitado de explicaciones,
también lo puede hacer cualquier otro ambiente. Así pasa con la Tierra. Así pasa con la Tierra contaminada.
El factor limitante, allí y aquí, no son los recursos, porque hay muchos,
sino el conocimiento, que es escaso.
Esta mirada cósmica basada en el conocimiento puede -- y pienso que debería
-- hacernos sentir muy especiales. pero debería hacernos sentir vulnerables,
porque significa que sin el conocimiento específico necesario para sobrevivir
los constantes desafíos del Universo, no sobreviviremos a ellos.
¡Basta con una supernova que explote a unos pocos años luz de distancia, y todos moriremos!
Martín Rees escribió recientemente un libro acerca de nuestra vulnerabilidad frente a todo tipo de cosas,
desde la astrofísica, a experimentos científicos que resulten mal,
y lo más importante al terrorismo con armas de destrucción masiva.
Él cree que la civilización sólo tiene un 50% de probabilidades de sobrevivir a este siglo.
Creo que el hablará más tarde en esta conferencia.
Ahora, no creo que probabilidad sea la categoría apropiada para discutir esta cuestión.
Pero estoy de acuerdo con él en esto. Podemos sobrevivir, o podemos fallar y no sobrevivir.
No depende de las probabilidades, sino de si creamos oportunamente el conocimiento relevante.
El peligro tiene precedentes. Se extinguen especies todo el tiempo.
Civilizaciones desaparecen. La gran mayoría de todas las especies y de todas las civilizaciones
que han alguna vez existido son ahora historia.
Y si queremos ser la excepción a eso, entonces lógicamente nuestra única esperanza
es usar la única característica que distingue a nuestra especie,
y a nuestra civilización, de todas las demás.
Es decir, nuestra relación especial con las leyes de la física.
Nuestra habilidad para crear nuevas explicaciones, nuevos conocimientos -- para ser el centro de la existencia.
Déjenme aplicar ésto a una controversia vigente actualmente,
no porque quiera abogar por alguna solución en particular,
sino sólo para ilustrar lo que quiero decir.
La controversia es el calentamiento global.
Ahora bien, yo soy físico, pero no el tipo de físico adecuado. En lo que concierne al calentamiento global,
soy sólo un lego. Y lo racional para un lego es tomarse en serio
la teoría científica vigente. De acuerdo a esa teoría,
ya es muy tarde para evitar un desastre.
Si, porque nuestra mejor opción actual para prevenir las emisiones de CO2
con algo como el Protocolo de Kyoto, con sus restricciones de actividad económica
y su enorme costo de cientos de miles de millones de dólares o lo que sea,
entonces ese ya es un desastre, sea como sea que se mire.
Y las acciones por las que se aboga ni siquiera apuntan a resolver el problema,
sólo postergarlo un poco. Así que ya es muy tarde para evitarlo, y
probablemente ha sido muy tarde para evitarlo, incluso antes que alguien se diera cuenta del problema.
Probablemente ya era muy tarde en los 1970s,
cuando la mejor teoría científica disponible nos decía que las emisiones industriales
estaban por precipitar una nueva era del hielo en la que miles de millones morirían.
La lección a sacar de eso me parece clara,
y no sé por qué no es considerada en el debate público.
Es que no siempre podemos saber. Cuando sabemos de un desastre inminente,
y como resolverlo aun costo menor que el costo mismo del desastre,
entonces no va a haber mucha discusión, realmente.
Pero ninguna precaución, y ningún principio de precaución,
puede evitar problemas que aún no visualizamos.
Por lo tanto, necesitamos un postura de solución de problemas, no sólo de prevención de problemas.
Es cierto que una onza de prevención equivale a una libra de cura,
pero eso es sólo si sabemos qué prevenir.
Si a usted le han golpeado la nariz, entonces la ciencia de la medicina no
consiste en enseñarle cómo evitar golpes.
Si la ciencia médica dejara de buscar curas y se concentrara sólo en prevencióm,
entonces lograría muy poco de ambas.
El mundo está actualmente lleno de planes para forzar reducciones
en emisiones de gas, a cualquier costo.
Debería estar lleno de planes para reducir la temperatura,
y de planes para vivir en temperaturas más altas.
Y no a cualquier costo, sino eficientemente y de modo barato. Y planes como esos existen,
cosas como enjambres de espejos en el espacio para deflectar la luz solar,
y promover que organismos acuáticos se alimenten con más dióxido de carbono.
Por el momento, esas cosas son investigaciones marginales.
No son centrales en el esfuerzo humano para enfrentar el problema, o problemas en general.
Y con problemas de los que aún no somos conscientes, la habilidad de arreglar algo --
no sólo la buena suerte de evitar indefinidamente -- es nuestra única esperanza,
no sólo de resolver los problemas, sino de sobrevivir.
Así que tomen dos tablas de piedra, y graben en ellas.
En una de ellas, graben "Los problemas tienen solución."
En la otra graben "Los problemas son inevitables."
Gracias (Aplausos)